lorsque les soldats ennemis se rendent, ils
deviennent prisonniers de guerre
voici les Conventions de Genève les
prisonniers sont évacués de la
zone de combat dès que possible après leur
capture pour les mettre hors de danger à
leur arrivée dans les camps de transit connus sous le nom de
collecte voici leur
destination finale un United  Camp de prisonniers de
guerre des Nations Unies établi loin derrière la
zone de combat conformément à la
Convention ces camps sont clairement
identifiables depuis les airs pour empêcher
les avions ennemis de bombarder leurs propres hommes
le camp est divisé en plusieurs enceintes
pour aider au contrôle des prisonniers les nouveaux
arrivants entrent  le complexe d'accueil
où ils seront traités et resteront
séparés jusqu'à ce que la
période d'incubation normale de tout Behrman qu'ils pourraient transporter soit
passé.
les prisonniers de guerre malades et blessés ont
reçu la même considération accordée aux
soldats des Nations Unies. les
camions et ambulances disponibles sont utilisés pour leur
évacuation  ceux nécessitant des
soins médicaux ou transportés directement à t  '
hôpital des camps ces prisonniers reflètent
les conditions difficiles dans leur armée beaucoup
ont été malades pendant longtemps avant d'être
capturés certains sont de fervents communistes mais
la majorité ont peu de connaissances sur
la véritable cause de la guerre et
ignoraient les forces qu'ils
combattaient leur efficacité  sur le
terrain est leur nombre écrasant, mais
face à la
puissance de feu supérieure des Nations Unies, ils sont tués ou
capturés, c'est alors l'ennemi,
même par temps sous zéro, il est généralement
mal vêtu pendant la
saison hivernale, beaucoup souffrent d'engelures aux
extrémités, en particulier  des pieds, des
mains et des oreilles
au cours de la première année du conflit coréen,
bien plus de 150 000 ennemis sont devenus
prisonniers de guerre pour prévenir les épidémies, les
prisonniers ont reçu des vaccins contre
les dactylographes et les
équipes de prisonniers de guerre entraînés
contre la variole.  pour
s'assurer que l'éradication est
complète
et pour beaucoup c'est leur premier soulagement
fr  om les poux de tête au cours des années
encore des prisonniers de guerre formés sont utilisés
pour
gérer les casquettes Clippers et les serviettes la gestion des casquettes prendra également
des dispositions pour fournir des fournitures de cantine
telles que du matériel de rasage de savon des
brosses à dents du dentifrice et la lumière
PW pour une identification facile
l'ancienne licence les uniformes suppurés
peuvent rarement  être nettoyé et réédité le programme du camp
comprend de la gymnastique suédoise en groupe
c'est une méthode efficace pour maintenir un
bon moral et chaque enceinte organise
ses propres cours après plusieurs mois dans
le camp de base il est possible de constater une
nette amélioration de l'apparence
des prisonniers que
le campus a inspectés  fréquemment par des
représentants du Comité international
de la Croix-Rouge des
représentants des prisonniers élus
au scrutin secret conformément à la
Convention de Genève pour discuter librement de
tous les griefs des prisonniers les
délégués de la Croix-Rouge sont également libres d'
examiner chaque phase des opérations du camp,
y compris  l'administration médicale
du  camp,
ils sont également intéressés par les
facilités offertes aux prisonniers pour
participer à
des activités intellectuelles et éducatives maintenir un
camp de prisonniers de guerre en vertu des
dispositions strictes de la Convention de Genève est une
tâche difficile mais dans ce premier
camp à être exploité sous l'égide des Nations
Unies, le  le personnel de la police militaire
affecté à cette tâche peu glorieuse mais
importante fait le travail
à aucun moment la force de garde ne peut se détendre de nouveaux
prisonniers arrivent à n'importe quelle heure en tout
nombre et parce qu'ils apportent la saleté et la
famine avec eux, ils doivent recevoir
une attention
médicale immédiate ici à  les
camps de prisonniers de guerre en Corée, les ennemis capturés
par leurs propres expériences quotidiennes
apprennent les avantages de la démocratie car
ils en viennent de plus en plus à apprécier
que le traitement juste et humain qui
leur est accordé par les forces des Nations Unies les femmes
prisonnières de guerre sont traitées avec tout ce qui leur est
dû  compte tenu de leur sexe, ils sont logés
dans une enceinte séparée complète avec wi  th toutes les
commodités
ceux qui méritent d'être formés et expérimentés aident
à soigner leurs malades et blessés à
tenir un compte précis des
prisonniers chaque matin midi et soir
il y a un décompte des prisonniers
rassemblés par groupes de cinq devant
leurs tentes à un seul  le commandement s'est déplacé vers
le centre et forme des rangs de dix qui
sont ensuite comptés sous la supervision
des commandants composés la
préparation de tonnes de
juste avant chaque repas l'équipement de masse est
soigneusement une portion de soupe est sur le
manuel quotidien servi dans des récipients
improvisés à partir de boîtes jetées
le  aliments de base riz et orge mélangés à du
poisson et des légumes maintiennent une
alimentation équilibrée et préviennent la perte de poids ou le
développement de carences nutritionnelles
la ration alimentaire quotidienne des détenus est
suffisante en quantité, qualité et
variété pour les maintenir en bonne santé